there's this sort of conventional wisdom
or common sense or actually both of
those terms often don't make sense but
there is this sort of conventional
wisdom that trump voters made the choice
to vote for Donald Trump because if so
called the economic anxiety right and
that in particular Trump was sort of
speaking to the economic anxieties of
middle class and often rural white
voters to a better degree to a greater
degree then Hillary Clinton did and so
voila they voted for Donald Trump
instead of Hillary Clinton and the New
York Times is a really good report out
on a new study by the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences that points
in a very very different direction and
one that I actually think makes more
more sense when you really examine it
critically to explain why many trumpets
ended up voting for Donald Trump and so
it is true that according to this study
the white male boating contingent
particularly the white Christian male
voting contingent was moved to vote for
Trump but not by economic anxiety but
instead by fear of losing their status
and the study found that mostly people
voted along party lines as is typically
the case in presidential elections
Republicans mostly voted for Donald
Trump Democrats mostly voted for Hillary
Clinton but among independents and among
people who cross voted meaning Democrats
voting for Trump or Republicans voting
for Hillary Clinton
those who ended up voting for Donald
Trump were disproportionately likely to
see their status in society as
threatened in some way more likely to
see whites and or Christians and/or men
as facing new discrimination and this is
not just like a cherry pick data point
while every other study says no economic
anxiety was the reason there's another
study the Public Religion Research
Institute did a similar survey and it
also found that this contingent of white
Christian men were moved to vote for
Trump disproportionately because of
their fear of being displaced in the
culture which is a very similar result
and when you think about it it makes a
lot of sense did voters
really care about bad trade deals per se
they told themselves that they did even
though many of them didn't actually have
the economic understanding to really get
what it meant but it's that they saw in
Trump the guy that would prevent people
in Asia or Hispanics from Latin America
from taking their jobs away and thus
questioning or putting in peril their
status Asians and factories weren't
going to be as likely to take jobs if
Donald Trump was the president is it
because of a nuanced understanding of
how Trump would do trade no but it's the
idea that it would protect their status
in society and when you look at the
results and you pair them up with Trump
policy ideas I guess we'd call them very
generally policy ideas although they
don't all actually translate to real
policy it makes a lot of sense there's
this sort of psychology of superiority
of privilege that exists and if you see
Hispanics or immigrants or minorities
non-christians women if you see them as
achieving not superior but equal status
in society comparatively you're losing
status right and that will influence you
to vote for the candidate who you at
least perceive might help you maintain
that status this relates the
minimum-wage phenomenon one of the
income groups when you do surveys of who
supports an increase to the minimum wage
and who is against an increase to the
minimum wage it's not the upper middle
class that overwhelmingly opposes
minimum wage increases it's not the rich
or the ultra rich although some do
oppose it it's not even often the middle
class the people making just more than
minimum wage are one of the groups that
most commonly opposes increases to the
minimum wage because what separates them
from the minimum wage workers not that
much in their mind and it is the exact
same psychological phenomenon that we
see here among a lot of Trump voters and
by the way when you look at history and
you look at when politics has been done
to avoid losing some kind of privileged
status be it a real
village status or a perceived privilege
status things often don't go well at all
so I think that in addition to the sort
of coalescing and catalyzing of a lot of
these extremist groups that we've seen
under Donald Trump the idea of people
voting to prevent a loss of what they
see as a privileged status is also a
really concerning thing I also wonder
how this will influence the Bernie would
have won crowd OH the idea behind that
theory was that Bernie was an economic
populist so he wouldn't have lost those
Rust Belt states like he wouldn't have
lost Pennsylvania and Michigan because
he talked about trade and he talked
about NAFTA but Bernie didn't do that
race-baiting stuff he didn't do that
right-wing identity politics so maybe
there's a case to be made that Trump
could be Bernie - I don't know there is
it that these numbers certainly go more
towards that story than the one that we
have heard which is Bernie definitely
would have won I actually don't know the
answer to that because the entire the
entire general election campaign would
have been very different
Trump was running against Bernie Sanders
so I don't know how useful it is to
really speculate about Bernie would have
won or Bernie would not have won I know
that I would have voted for Bernie in
the general the same way I voted for him
and the in the primary had he been the
candidate I'm gonna be very interested
to see data from the upcoming midterms
outlining what factors motivate voting
one way or the other because you'll have
this potential you've got the economic
anxiety narrative you've got the fear of
losing privileged status narrative and
then you also have now the sort of
counter Trump move or influence momentum
which has led to a lot of Democratic
wins and special elections over the last
year so certainly midterm 2018 data will
be very interesting to look at the video
you just finished watching was made
possible by you through the membership
program you can sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership we
are viewer supported independent media
you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership